elizabeth warren's humiliating
self-owned the media give President
Trump a reason to question fake news
again and Hillary will never leave I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
all Elizabeth Moore and the smoke
signals for 2020 have never been
stronger but it seems as though she has
just collapsed her own wigwam I don't
know I don't even know man or her TV or
TV I don't know in any case it's just
it's spectacular so I can't wait to get
this an Elizabeth Warren's story but
first let's talk about how you can save
save money on stamps so these days you
can save money on practically anything
by never having to leave your house
because time is money except you still
have to go to the post office for stamps
except d-d-don't anymore now you can go
over to stamps calm you can access all
the amazing services of the post office
right from your desk 24/7 when it is
convenient for you buy and print
official US postage for any letter and
any package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it up you
click print mail you none could not be
easier we use stamps calm here at the
Daily wire offices and it is spectacular
saves as time saves us money and right
now when you use promo code Shapiro you
get a special offer
55 bucks of free postage a digital scale
and a four week trial go to stamps calm
before you do anything else click on
that radio microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm and her promo code Shapiro
for that special deal 55 bucks of free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial go check it out right now
again stamps comm promo code Shapiro all
the services of the post office directly
at your fingertips it's pretty
spectacular which is why we use it
stamps commies that promo click Shapiro
for the special deal
alright so Elizabeth Warren making my
day great again
so Elizabeth Warren is the senator from
Massachusetts I knew her a little bit
when I was at Harvard Law School because
she was a property professor they're
pretty popular property professor the
first time I met her she literally the
first time I met her she was recruiting
for Harvard Law School and she ripped on
Rush Limbaugh so that was a pretty good
opener for what Elizabeth Warren was
politically well Elizabeth Warren today
decided that she would engage in the
most humiliating cell phone I have ever
seen in American politics I mean this is
like the best self owned of all time
this is the equivalent of that guy who
owned gold during the World Cup and then
got killed for it hopefully nothing bad
happens to Elizabeth Warren nobody is
calling for violence but this is a
really bad own-goal my goodness so we
have to travel
back in time to a time when Elizabeth
Warren claims that she was in fact a
Native American she said that she had
high Cherokee cheekbones she suggested
in a in a recipe book called powwow Chow
I kid you not that she was a Native
American and the recipe she submitted to
powwow Chow was a recipe again I kid you
not for a crab bisque because clearly
that was something the Cherokees made
back in the day crab bisque he noted
crab herds of the Oklahoma Plains that
her ancestors used to hunt elude with
Morin told this story over and over
about her Native American ancestry and
what she said was that their racist
members of her family couldn't accept
her parents romance because her mom was
partially Native American here's Hill
Elizabeth Warren telling the romantic
story actually you haven't wrong about
what it is I believe let's start there
okay my mom and dad were very much in
love with each other
and they wanted to get married and my
father's parents said absolutely not you
can't marry her because she's part
Cherokee and she's part Delaware and um
after fighting it as long as they could
my parents went off they eloped okay so
her parents eloped because her mom was
part Cherokee and part Delaware which
means you would think pretty hefty dose
of Native American ancestry right there
right I mean if if her family is worried
about it then sounds like that would be
some significant Native American
ancestry so President Trump didn't
believe this because it's nonsense they
had people actually checked into her
background they found there's no Native
American ancestry anywhere in the in the
time horizon of rationality so President
Trump went out on the campaign trail
this is back in 2017 I believe and he
was holding a rally in Montana
and he suggested that he would give her
a million dollars if she could prove her
native-american ancestry and we will say
I will give you a million dollars to
your favorite charity paid for by Trump
if you take the test that it shows
you're an idiot you know
so today Elizabeth Warren came forward
with the evidence that she was in fact
Native American now I think that it is
important to note if you don't believe
in media bias you have to check out the
headlines today because the headlines
today are truly astonishing the headline
today
The Daily Beast suggests that there is
strong evidence that she is Native
American
okay this it says this is the actual
title Elizabeth Warren DNA test reveals
Native American ancestry her claims to
indigenous heritage had been ridiculed
by Trump CNN had a headline about
Elizabeth Warren same thing says Trump
offered 1 million dollars now he says
who cares an Elizabeth Warren releases
tests with strong evidence of ancestry
and then analysis why Elizabeth Warren
is number one in our new 20/20 ranking
so CNN obviously has a pretty strong
agenda here so what this would suggest
if you just read those headlines is she
took a DNA test and it found that a
great grandparent was Native American or
something well not much so she took a
DNA test and here's what each other's
according to Boston Globe the analysis
of Warren's DNA was done by Carlos
Bustamante a Stanford University
professor and expert in the field who
won a 2010 McArthur fellowship also
known as a genius grant for his work on
tracking population migration via DNA
analysis he concluded that the vast
majority of Lauren's ancestry is
European but he added that the results
strongly support the existence of an
unadorned it means Bustamante calculated
that Warren's pure Native American
ancestor appears in her family tree in
the range of 6 to 10 generations ago six
to ten generations ago in other words
her actual Native American ancestor
could be Pocahontas now it takes you
back like 200 years that's it just just
to be straight about this her claim that
she has Native American ancestry was
that her parent her mom was so Native
American that she was discriminated
against by her dad's family that is not
the same thing as her great-great-great
great-great grandparent minimum was a
Native American not not the same thing
at all and by the way that is not the
outer limit of the test the test shows
that at best at best
she was a sixth generation Native
American at worst at worst its tenth
which would mean that she had an
ancestor her great-great-great
great-great-great great-great-great
grandparent who is Native American
okay the best part of this Boston
Globe's story it's really really
spectacular
so it says the inherence imprecision of
the six page DNA analysis could provide
fodder for morons critics yeah I think
if for a great-great-great grandmother
was a Native American that puts her at
1/32 American Indian but no one says
she's 1/32 the minimum writing the
minimum is that she is one I think it
was one 512 or something she's not that
like one thirty seconds is not actually
a a sixth generation Native American
that's that's like a fourth generation
Native American in any case the report
includes the possibility that she is
just one 1,024 Native American
if the ancestor is ten generations back
one 1024 I love this so here here's the
even better part to make up for the
dearth of Native American ancestry DNA
Bustamante used samples from Mexico Peru
and Colombia to stand in for Native
American so notice he knew when you use
like Cherokee DNA to match her up
he used Mexican Peruvian and Colombian
DNA to match up so what it really shows
is that she's won 1,024 Mexican Peruvian
or Colombian so awesome awesome I love
this
it says Warren has 12 times more Native
American blood than a white person from
Great Britain and 10 times more than a
white person from Utah the report found
well there's only one problem with that
what the actual study shows that the
average American in the United States of
any race the average American in the
United States is 0.18 percent is 0.18
percent Native American may that is what
and by the way you're not accepted as a
Native American a Native American tribe
enlist or at least 1/16 Native American
meaning you had a great grandparent who
is Native American so we are now going
back 10 generations to try and claim
that she's a Native American because she
claimed I guess a University of
Pennsylvania Native American heritage
and all the rest he is point zero zero
nine percent Native American and she's
bragging about this right this is her
claim and the media are saying well they
should put this thing to bed this should
put it to bed that is not that is not
what she said that's not what she said
at all
at all it's spectacular
she's 99.999% white Matt Walsh is a good
tweet about this after finding out that
Warren is a staggering 99.999% white
Richard Spencer is expected to endorse
her for president oh I love it so much I
love it so much so by the way according
to science just want to get this
straight according to science if you are
one 1,024 Native American that is strong
evidence of Native American ancestry if
you have two x-chromosomes
this doesn't mean you're a woman that's
according to the media
this is science people this isn't
politics its science so I have suggested
publicly as others have done I'm not the
only one or person to have suggested
this president Trump should not give 1
million dollars to Elizabeth Warren he
should give her one one thousand 24th of
a million dollars he should sign her a
$900 check because that's how Native
American she is it's so good and he
should put it he should print it out any
giant Publishers Clearing House check
and he should sign it to Elizabeth
Warren and in the subject line destroyed
failing 2020 campaign it's just
spectacular it's just spectacular so I
love it and again you have to love the
media bias here if anybody claimed this
on the right are you kidding me if I
claimed that I had Native American
ancestry and then people look well Ben
you're pretty Jewish yeah well you know
if I take a 23andme test and it shows
that ten generations ago maybe someone
with some DNA in common with a Colombian
person was in my ancestry would that
make you Native American also I do love
this yeah the the again the idea that
she is Native American based on an
ancestor ten generations ago that's
insane
there's not even the greatest racists
like the greatest racists on earth would
not call her Native American the people
who hate Native Americans would not call
her Native American based on that
ancestry no Nazis not real fond of Jews
they cut off Jewish ancestry at second
generation at third generation
they said if you have four German
grandparents then you are considered
fully German okay and those people were
super giant racists so the left is now
even more racist than the biggest racist
because they are saying that if you have
one tiny drop of Native American
ancestry from 400 years ago now your
Native American what are Native
Americans feel about this it can't be
great
it can't be great really really
astonishing so it's so good we'll have
more on this I love it so I love it so
ah it's so great I have more on this in
just one second - first let's talk about
the air that you are breathing so
there's a new study it just came out of
China and it discovered that air
pollution causes a huge reduction in
intelligence which might explain our
nation's politics right now high
pollution levels lluvia it led to
significant drops in test scores with
language and arithmetic the average
impact equivalence having lost an entire
year of Education well now we know what
happened to all the people who protest
me when I go to college campuses but it
is important for you to have clean air
in your home with ninety five percent of
the global population breathing unsafe
air you ought to have filters in your
house that work filter by comm is
America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
you can choose from over 600 sizes
including custom options that chip free
within 24 hours plus they support
working Americans manufacturing all
their filters right here in America save
5% when you subscribe for auto
replacement so you will never forget to
change your filters ever again filter by
will save you time money you're gonna
breathe better
apparently you become more intelligence
in the process which is awesome for you
so stop procrastinating go to filter Bui
calm that's filter by comm tell them
that we sent you we use filter by here
in the office I've used it at my house
as well go check it out right now filter
bu why calm that's filter by calm so
spectacular so Elizabeth Warren just
making a mockery of herself and not even
knowing it in the media playing along
now the question is what motivated her
to do this right what what made her do
this what made Elizabeth Warren think
this is a great idea the answer is and
what Manor think by the way how the hell
great idea that you'd think this was she
went home and she filmed a video with a
bunch of her family members complaining
about how Trump was mean for suggesting
she didn't have a Native American
ancestry
uh-huh she obviously is prepping for a
presidential run but this is so my you
know how you know wait Elizabeth Warren
is look at the back of this paper
okay this paper right here is less white
than than Elizabeth Warren is because
you can still see the ink through it a
little bit okay loser with Warren is
more white than this piece of paper and
yet she is proclaiming I just made am
American it's so good it's just it's so
good okay so I love it but why did she
do this she did this because she knew
the media would cover for anyway so the
so the the media wrote a bunch of
headlines saying that now she had been
now she had been justified she had been
justified in her accusations she had
been justified in her claims and she is
calling on President Trump to sign her a
million dollar check because she is
possibly point zero nine percent Native
American solid solid stuff there but
she's right because the media do back
her play no matter what she does the
media will back her play and that's
obvious from the weekend's media
coverage the media you know it's funny
folks on the Left suggest that the
people on the right are better cleaners
we cling to God and we cling to guns and
we cling to and we cling to our American
status we cling to our borders I mean
clinging to our language we cling to all
sorts of terrible things remember Barack
Obama blamed evil republicanism on being
bitter clingers Elizabeth Warren is
bitterly clinging on to the sanera t'v
in the media are bitterly clinging on
along with her and then they are
clinging on to a bunch of other false
narratives that they are putting out now
all they have to do I've said this on
CNN all that the media have to do in
order to undermine President Trump is
just try to stick to the truth they
can't do it there's nothing that they
can do that that will force them to
stick the truth and I have the evidence
of this so over the weekend there are
two separate two separate major media
stories that turned out to be basically
false about President Trump Story number
one here is 8:00 in NBC tweet about a
rally the President Trump did I believe
Friday night it says watch president
Trump says robert e lee was a great
general during ohio rally calling the
Confederate leader incredible now you
think well that's bad stuff you probably
shouldn't call a Confederate leader
incredible it is true by the way that
robert e lee was a good general Eiling
rage chatter nobody was a good general
that doesn't mean that he was a good
person or that he believed good things
but that was the headline from UC News
the headline from NBC News is that Trump
said that Robert Ely was a great general
and called the Confederate leader
incredible now here is what President
Trump actually said about robbery Lee
here's the clip of President Trump
talking and one day it was looking
really bad and Lincoln just said
you hardly knew his name and they said
don't take him he's got a drinking
problem
and Lincoln said I don't care what
problem he has you guys aren't winning
and his name was Grant General Grant and
Lincoln said I don't care if he's an
alcoholic frankly give me six or seven
more just like him
okay so there is Trump actually talking
about Brent what he was saying is that
robert e lee was a great general who has
overcome by grant he was not saying that
robert ii lose a wonderful wonderful
person standing for wonderful things so
NBC has to actually correct it so Trump
tweets this out he says you guys got
this wrong he got this wrong so here's
president Trump's tweet NBC News has
totally and purposely changed the put
and meaning of my story about general
robert e lee and General Ulysses Grant
was actually a shout out to warrior
grant and the great state in which he
was born
as usual dishonest reporting even
mainstream media embarrassed
an NBC he had to suite out a correction
they tweeted out a full correction
correction an earlier tweet
misidentified the general president
Trump described as incredible at a rally
in Ohio it was general ulysses s grant
not general robert e lee an attached
video clip lacked the full context for
trump's remark here is the full clip it
took NBC News two full days to retract
it two full days and that wasn't the
only example of ridiculous media bias in
the last 48 hours
so CBS tweeted this out about President
Trump on 60 minutes so last night
President Trump was on 60 minutes here's
what they tweeted they tweeted President
Trump on his treatment of Christine
Blasi Ford at rally the accuser of Jos
now Justice Brett Kavanaugh it doesn't
matter we won makes it sound like
question was do you care that you mocked
Christine Blasi Ford and Trump says it
doesn't matter we won well there's only
one problem that is clearly not what
Trump was saying like clearly not what
Trump was saying here is president Trump
actually talking we need the actual clip
of President Trump talking from from 60
minutes and here he is here he is in
context that is absolutely not what he
saying
professor Blasi Ford you mimicked her
had I not made that speech we would not
have won I was just saying she didn't
seem to know anything
no and you tried to destroy a life of a
man who has been extraordinary why did
you have to make fun of her I didn't
really make fun well they were like I
said is the person that we're talking
about didn't know the year the time the
place
professor quasi Ford got before the
Senate and and was asked what's the
worst moment she said when the two boys
laughed at me at my expense and then I
watched you mimic her and thousands of
people were laughing at her they can do
what they I will tell you the way now
justice Cavanaugh was traded has become
a big factor in the midterms have you
seen what's gone on with the polls what
did you have - well I think she was
treated with great respect
nobody honest like what do you think you
should do you think you treated her with
great residue so yeah I did but you seem
to be saying that she lied what you know
what I'm not gonna get into it because
we won it doesn't matter
we won okay so clearly he's not saying I
don't care that you're accusing me of
mocking her because we won he is saying
I'm not gonna get into this with you
it's over we're done the media covered
this as though he was saying that he
didn't care that he had mocked her which
is actually not what he said so they
took that out of context - it's just
amazing it's just amazing
so again when President Trump slams the
so-called fake news when they actually
are participating in fake news they
absolutely 100% deserve it they
absolutely 100% deserve all of it in a
second we're gonna go through an epic
episode of some good Trump bad Trump
because President Trump was on 60
minutes yesterday but first let's talk
about how you are going to relax
does this new cycle make you want to
relax do you need to relax a little bit
I mean I know your poem was from
laughter over Elizabeth Warren's claim
that she's Native American but still if
you're a little bit stressed out over
the midterm elections or anything else
in your life you really need to talk to
my friends over at Zeile you go to Zeile
calm or zeals iPhone or Android app z ee
l comm and you can select from top local
licensed pre-screened massage therapists
choose your favorite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage Ben Zeile will then send you one
of their 10,000 licensed massage
therapists with a massage table music
and supplies to give you a five-star
massage scheduling booking payment fast
and easy even the tip is included 7 days
a week 365 days a year
as the Oh massage therapist can be at
your door in as little as an hour
they've been featured in The Wall Street
Journal New York Times vogue Good
Morning America they are on demand they
make it really easy I've gotten zero
massages for pretty much every member of
my family at this point my sister my mom
my dad my in-laws my wife I mean really
seals great they and all of their other
folks are terrific to help you get
started right now our listeners can get
25 bucks off their first massage with
promo code Ben at z ee l comm promo club
and right now go to zeal comm get a
special offer when you try zeal today
enter promo code Ben or get 25 but to
get 25 bucks off your first in-home
massage go check it out right now
okay so final though I just have to say
this final note on this Elizabeth Warren
thing the the left is now trying to
Gaslight so they say Elizabeth Warren
says that she is Native American and
then we go home no she's not and then
she says okay well here's the DNA test
proving that I am pretty much not Native
American I would go right because we
said she wasn't they said no no no we
said pretty much not ten generations ago
she had a Native American ancestor and
we're like right but that's not really
Native American like well you must be a
racist because you don't think that
she's Native American based on an
ancestor ten generations ago with
Colombian DNA okay you don't get to do
that and Elizabeth Warren is is
obviously kicking into height roll
height roll mode so she actually tweeted
out this morning that President Trump is
that President Trump has apparently
forgotten about his promises to pay her
money it says having some memory
problems mr. Trump should we call for a
doctor here's something you won't forget
mr. president
the least popular president in modern
history and your allies will go down
hard in the midterm elections 22 days
tick tock tick tock
so basically Michael a Vinod he just
took over Elizabeth Warren's sweater
feed good luck with with all of this for
the Democrats now with all that said
President Trump was on 60 minutes last
night he did overall I think a pretty
good job because he was dealing with an
interviewer in Lesley Stahl who is
wildly anti Trump really really hates
Trump and you can tell from the
questions but it was a pretty that's a
pretty epic episode of good Trump bad
Trump so I have been the progenitor like
the actual creator not ten generations
ago the actual creator of good trump bad
Trump yeah this model that says
sometimes the president says good things
and sometimes the president says bad
things and we have a theme song for we
haven't played it in a while but today
seemed a nap today so let's play a
little good Trump and Trump
[Music]
okay so on the good Trump side I have to
acknowledge that the President did quote
tweet me this morning which was kind of
fun so he watched my final Sunday
special on Fox News and he tweeted out
the only way to shut down the Democrats
new mob rules strategy is to stop them
called at the ballot box the fight for
America's future is never over Ben
Shapiro Thank You mr. president I
appreciate it so that's good Trump other
a good Trump he said something he said
some interesting things on 60 minutes
and when he talked about the Democrats
not wanting the country to heal this
obviously was criterias President Trump
going after the Democrats he is not
wrong about this considering that
Elizabeth Warren today is doing the
everybody hates you mr. Trump and my
Native American ancestry is real and
Hillary saying no civility for
Republicans and all the rest here is
president from talking about Democrats
wanting to divide the country we need to
be healed we need I don't think they
want to heal yet I'll be home yeah I saw
Hillary Clinton made a really nasty
statement I don't think they want to be
healed I do want to heal okay so I agree
that the Democrats don't want the
country to heal I'm not sure that
President Trump is the most healing
president but we will count this in the
category of good Trump in the category
of bad Trump here was president from
talking about Saudi Arabia so he has
made a couple of comments what he said
on 60 minutes was not bad but Saudi
Arabia is enmeshed in a massive scandal
right now because there's this guy named
Jamal khashoggi and Jamal cushaw he was
a person who wrote op eds for the
Washington Post he was a longtime
retainer of the Saudi royal family and a
critic of the regime he entered the
Saudi consulate in Istanbul Turkey on
October 2nd seeking documents relevant
to a divorce
the Turkish government claims that they
have proof that a Saudi hit squad
murdered him inside the consulate chops
his body up and then dispatched the
remains in a black van to a private
plane headed for Saudi Arabia there's
not a lot of doubt that kesaji is dead
at this point
this is creating worldwide consternation
against the Saudi government and in
particular against Prince Mohammed bin
Sultan who's considered the new leader
of Saudi Arabia the new dictator of
Saudi Arabia a few comments are
necessary on this to understand what's
going on exactly
number one Saudi Arabia is a tyrannical
dictatorship led by people who are
tyrannical dictators it's a monarchy
they chop people's hands off
they imprison dissidents they're not a
human rights friendly country Muhammad
bin Sultan was supposed to be a reformer
but even as a reformer he's still the
dictator of Saudi Arabia this is not a
supremely shocking story on any level
other than we know the name of the guy
who has disappeared as opposed to
presumably many other people whose names
we don't know who have been disappeared
second the Turkish government has a
pretty strong interest in trying to
humiliate the Saudis because the Turkish
government has basically been anti Saudi
for years that are in bed with the
Iranian government at this point and to
a certain extent in bed with the Syrian
government as well all of that said the
Turkish government releasing evidence in
an attempt to make it look like they are
our friends air Dewan who's a leader of
Turkey also in Islamist thug who has
imprisoned dissidents and killed
dissidents - so there are no good guys
in this part of the world at least not
in leadership positions in any case the
call for the United States to distance
itself from the Saudi Arabian government
after all of this I think is appropriate
but I think it's also appropriate to
note that the outsized consternation
with regard to Khashoggi which when I
say outsized I don't mean that it's
inappropriate it's totally appropriate
but when compared to the amount of
consternation over turkey imprisoning
thousands of people and until a minute
ago imprisoning a US pastor or Syria
murdering half a million people or Iran
pursuing terrorism across the region
it's it is amazing how the human brain
has the capacity to hone in on a single
incidence of evil in a way that it
doesn't on literally hundreds of
thousands of incidents of evil but with
all of that said the United States does
have to do something if the Saudi
Arabian government is calling dissonance
back to consulates and then murdering
them that's not a that is that is a bad
thing here's President Trump on 60
minutes talking about it he changed his
tune a little bit today they are
honoring military equipment everybody in
the world wanted that order Russia
wanted it China wanted it we wanted it
we got it so would you cut that off no I
don't know what I don't want to do
Boeing Lockheed Raytheon all these cuts
I don't want to hurt jobs I don't want
to lose an order like that there are
other ways of
to use a word that's a pretty harsh word
but there's true okay so you know when
he says that he wants to maintain
certain economic ties that's not great
Trump right he needs to actually be
exerting pressure on the Saudis for
reform now he has to do that carefully
because he also doesn't want to give a
lot of leeway and leverage to the
Iranians who are enemies with the Saudi
regime and have been fighting a proxy
war in Yemen with the Saudis like there
again there are no good guys in this
particular area of the world but with
that said yeah the president ought to be
signaling some pretty harsh rhetoric
with regard to the kesaji situation he
is not so that one files under bad Trump
today he said that the Saudi Arabian
government denies it they say that it's
not real so we're just going to ignore
it that is not great stuff from the
president okay other stuff that the
president said during the 60 Minutes
interview here is some other bad Trump
here's President Trump i'm kim jong hoon
the the dictator another evil dictator
and he had some more morons for him why
do you love that guy look look I get
along with him okay him okay
that's just like you know it's like an
embrace well let it be at a bris let it
be whatever it is he's a Chad guy look
let it be whatever it is I get along
with him really well I have a good
energy with him have a good chemistry
with him look at the horrible threats
that were made no more threats no more
threats okay so you know him him talking
about Kim that way is not good either
you actually have to demonstrate a
strong hand and president Trump did that
early in his presidency with him but
he's not really doing that anymore so
there's a lot of good Trump bad frump
happening with with regard to 60 minutes
but that's who the president is and it
is important to note that his ups and
downs are indicative of the man's mind I
mean that's just to present in Trump it
is so in just a second I want to get to
the other big story of the weekend which
was these violent clashes happening in
Portland and New York between an Tifa
and the proud boys but first let's talk
about expressvpn so you need to protect
your internet access whether you're in a
cafe or a hotel we often rely on public
Wi-Fi to use the internet on the go but
something as simple as paying your bills
online from a Starbucks could actually
leave your data exposed a hacker could
easily intercept your information
stealing passwords credit cards personal
it's not just hackers either government
agencies like the NSA they monitor the
Internet
and it could scoop up your activity so
what can you do to defend yourself well
the software I use to protect my online
activity from spies and data thieves is
called expressvpn expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly in
the background of my computer phone and
tablet expressvpn secures and anonymizes
my internet browsing and encrypts my
data it hides my public IP address so
using expressvpn I can safely search on
public Wi-Fi anytime I want and it costs
less than seven bucks a month comes with
a 30-day money-back guarantees he can
try it see if you like it you will to
take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months for free go to expressvpn comm
slash Ben that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
been for three months free with one year
package again expressvpn secure your
internet now that's expressvpn comm
slash Ben to learn more go check it out
right now okay so while President Trump
was participating in good Trump bad
Trump Hillary Clinton was just
participating in normal Hillary which is
just bad Hillary there is no that
Hillary we'll get to that in just a
second you're gonna have to go over to
Daily wires comm and subscribe for the
rest of today's hilarious and
entertaining episode $9.99 a month get
to a subscription to the daily wire that
means you also get this show live
Michael Moses show live Andrew Clavin
show live in you get access to another
kingdom we have new episodes season two
of another Kingdom coming up and first
one came out on Friday it has some
pretty awesome graphics and and art
attached to it so that's pretty fun also
it's almost time for our next episode of
the conversation tomorrow at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific drew Andrew
Clavin will be taking your questions and
answering them live on air
hosted by Alicia Krause who'll get a
full hour of Drew's infinite wisdom that
famously produces world-class leftist
tears finely ground and honed to
perfection by blind nuns in the Swiss
Alps as always this episode will be free
for everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube but only subscribers can ask the
questions so don't miss Drew's next
chapter of another kingdom either by the
way which as I say was performed by
Michael moles and today's subscribers
get exclusive access to episode 3 as
well this one is titled the beast
obviously about president Trump if
you're not a subscriber you won't be
able to watch new episodes of season 2
until Friday so what exactly are you
waiting for go to daily wire comm
subscribe to watch the first and second
seasons of another Kingdom and you get
all of these glories all these wonderful
glories for 99 bucks a year which is
cheaper than the $9.99 a month do your
math don't be like Elizabeth Warren know
how math works go check that out right
now and when you get that $99 a year
subscription you get this the very
greatest and beverage vessels look at
this feast your eyes upon it
the leftist tears Hut or a cold tumbler
feel the inspiration you draw just from
setting your eyes upon this glory you're
not going to know the power that flows
through your body until you hold this
thing in your hand and that you're only
gonna be able to do that when you have a
$99 a year subscription ok go check that
out
we haven't bunch of great so many
specials coming up to subscribe it
iTunes YouTube leave us a review only 5
stars are accepted go check that out we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all right so Hillary Clinton is the
other side of the good Trump bad Trump
routine so president Trump has good
Trump and bad Trump Hillary Clinton just
has bad bad Hillary there is no such
thing as good Hillary so Hillary came
out over the weekend and said that Bill
Clinton should not have resigned over
Monica Lewinsky because he did not abuse
his power in any way I do love that she
is considered a hero a heroine of the
feminist movement pretty spectacular
stuff from the left here here as Hillary
MIT Clinton
in retrospect do you think Bill should
have resigned in the wake of the Monica
Lewinsky scan
not it wasn't an abuse of power no no
there are people who look at the
incidents of the 90s and they say a
president of the United States cannot
have a consensual relationship with an
intern the power imbalances too was an
adult but let me ask you this where's
the investigation of the current
incumbent against whom numerous
allegations have been made so good so
good so I love this Trump should resign
because of allegations against him but
her husband shouldn't resign because of
allegations against him also he didn't
abuse power one he 49 year old president
of the United States was being serviced
by a 22 year old intern in the Oval
Office not an abuse of power in any way
good to know that power imbalance is no
longer a concern for feminists on the
left very exciting stuff also Hillary
came forth and said President Trump is a
sexist of course the reason that she
knows Trump is a sexist is because Trump
was mean to her if you watched the way
Trump debated me it was just imbued with
sexism making fun of me for preparing
well you know that's the old like oh
yeah the girl in the class who's always
prepared I don't need to be prepared
that really was now it happened at those
debates what happened is the Trump was
as much of a jerk to her as he is to
every other human being on the planet
and it didn't play well with her because
she's one of the most deeply unlikable
human beings on planet Earth just loved
it the Democrats have decided to
full-scale embrace the most radical
version of themselves you know they say
in acting that you have to get in touch
with your authenticity the Democrats are
certainly getting in touch with their
authenticity the problem is that deep
down Democratic leadership not
particularly charming Bernie Sanders is
another example of this so Bernie was on
Jake Tapper's show on CNN and Jay
tapper asked him about the inflammatory
rhetoric on the part of some folks in
the Democratic Party and Bernie a
follower of who's shot up a bunch of
Congress people last year came out and
said that it's not that bad if people
get mobbed in public places like it's
amazing that Bernie doesn't feel any
necessity to say anything here about
this sort of action you know I listen
again I don't blame Bernie Sanders for
that incident last year because unless
you are openly calling for violence I
don't blame you for somebody going and
doing violence but when Bernie Sanders
refuses to condemn mobbing in public
spaces he certainly is not making the
country a better place I am very
strongly in favor of mobilizing the
American people to stand up and fight
for economic justice and social justice
and racial and environmental justice and
I think we have to mobilize people I am
NOT a great fan of being rude or
disrupting activities but this is what I
will say this entire 2000 and election
campaign is gonna come down to two words
and that is voter turn up okay so he's
not a big fan of people getting over but
if people get rude that's sort of the
way that it is and voter turnout don't
want to dampen the enthusiasm it just
shows how the Democrats are willing to
flirt with the mob politics they've been
talking about for the last several
months
really since Maxine Waters broke out
into the open with it and they're
willing to do so on a regular basis
they're even willing to validate mob
violence on a regular basis over the
weekend The Washington Times reported
that Portland mayor Ted wheeler came
under fire over a viral video showing an
Tifa protesters blocking traffic and
harassing drivers but he says he
supports the decision by police to watch
from a distance without getting involved
he says I was appalled by what I saw in
the video but I support the Portland
Police Bureau's decision not to
intervene the whole incident will be
investigated the video was posted by
journalists and zine ago and it showed
protesters including members of an Tifa
and black lives matter blocking an
intersection and attempting to direct
traffic while officers on motorcycle
watched from a block away at one point
the activists chase down 74 year-old
Kent Hauser after he made a right turn
against their wishes pounding on his
silver Lexus and breaking a window the
car sustained thousands of dollars in
damage he told The Oregonian but mr.
wheeler insists the motorist should feel
completely safe coming into downtown
Portland well
all of this this lack of law enforcement
this lack of crackdowns on an Tifa it
leads to greater heights of violence
when other people who are ready for
violence show up in places where an Tifa
is now here has been my recommendation
for a very long time I speak at a lot of
public events where protesters show up
and some of those events protesters get
violent but I mean that that's happened
at Cal State Los Angeles had happened at
Penn State a little bit it happened
certainly at Berkeley where nine people
were arrested my recommendation has
always been because there been people
who said well should I come ready for
self-defense I've always said is look if
somebody hits you then defending
yourself is fine but you should come
ready to invoke the powers of the police
you should be ready to go to the police
and let law enforcement take care of the
problem we live in a volatile climate
enough that you don't have to go around
spoiling for a fight because if you
spoil for a fight the media is just
gonna play it as though you're the
instigator of the fight in the first
place
the reason I bring this up is because
over the weekend there are a couple of
violent incidents one in New York and
one in Portland and it's just not good
stuff it's not good stuff I'll explain
so first Portland so there was a March
called the Patriot
Patriot Pride I believe and it happened
in Portland over the weekend and it was
and it got ugly because aunt Eva showed
up and people basically started beating
the crap out of each other here's a
little bit of the brawl
[Music]
so if you can't see this you can see
people fighting with each other like
really swinging on each other
according to the Oregon live a
demonstration billed as a March for law
and order in the streets of Portland
descend into chaos as rival political
factions broke into bloody brawls
downtown Saturday night
members of the right-wing group patriot
player and their black the black clad
adversaries known as an tyfa used bear
spray bare fists and batons to thrash
each other outside Kelly's Olympian a
popular bar on Southwest Washington
Street the melee which lasted more than
a minute ended when riot cops rushed in
and fired pepper balls at the street
fighters now as I say what's happening
here is that groups like patriot prayer
which I are being cast as white
nationalist and I'm not seeing the
strong enough evidence to say that this
is a white nationalist group in any case
and this is coming from a guy who's
happy to say when I think people are
white nationalists right I did two
episodes after Charlottesville talking
about white nationalism and the evils of
the alt-right Patriot parrot was doing a
march in Portland specifically because
they wanted to show that antique food
was violent and Tifa showed up and it
looked like an Tifa instigated violence
and the folks at patriot prayer then got
into it with them including some of the
proud boys from gavin mcginnises group
and it got violent now as I say I think
that is perfectly worthwhile to publicly
march against violence and I think it's
okay to defend yourself too but there's
a difference between being willing to
defend yourself and spoiling for a fight
to the point where you are looking to
beat the living crap out of somebody
because number one you shouldn't be
looking to beat the living crap out of
people in aggressive fashion like once
the guys down the guys down now it's
time for law enforcement to come in and
number two it is perfectly obvious that
the media are going to play this as
though it is right-wing groups
instigating violence as opposed to ante
foe which has been violent every single
place it goes instigating violence
here's a little bit more video from that
brawl in Portland
it's a little hard to see if you can see
folks are marching and then it's about
to break down into violence and see in
the front people hitting each other or
swinging on each other people shouting
at each other okay and then there was
also a separate brawl in New York so in
New York there was a event at the New
York Metropolitan Club that Club had
been - faced by allegedly antiva over
the past couple of days and there was an
event for Gavin McInnes he's the leader
of the proud boys now again the media
have labeled the proud boys a white
nationalist group they're members of the
proud boys who are white nationalists
Gavin is not a white nationalist I know
Gavin Gavin is not a white nationalist
Gavin I think needs to be more strict
about who he involves as his friends but
to suggest that Gavin is a white
nationalist ignores any part of his
rhetoric that that's just not accurate
now with that said do the proud boys
spoil for a fight yeah they do and you
can see that in this particular video in
New York now an tifa's claiming that the
proud boys instigated the violence the
proud boys are claiming that any fight
instigated the violence apparently after
the event they walked out there's some
Antipa members somehow the violence gets
instigated and you end up with basically
20 members of the proud boys kicking the
living crap out of three members of an
tyfa
and then they won't get off these guys
they're picking them and then eventually
you'll see some members is sort of the
surrounding crowd actually pulling
people off of these guys because they
don't want them you know getting
arrested or killing somebody on the
street brawls fought in public streets
this is not civilization it's not
civilization and if the police won't do
their jobs this is gonna get worse and
worse and if mayor's aren't gonna do
their jobs it's gonna get worse and
worse New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
called on the FBI to investigate violent
clashes connected to the proud boys and
he blamed President Trump for the hatred
and violence he tied to the altercations
this is a state issue this is not a
federal issue
hey the state and city should
investigate every one of these incidents
and the people who instigate violence
should go to jail if the city was doing
that in the first place these brawls
would not be breaking out we've seen
them now in Sacramento we've seen them a
couple of times in Portland we've seen
them in Berkeley we have seen them now
in New York City this is all ugly stuff
yes be ready to defend yourself don't go
to events though spoiling for a fight be
there in coordination with the police if
you're on the side of law enforcement
you're doing something right and if the
left refuses to allow law enforcement to
do its job this sort of stuff is going
to become more and more prevalent and
it's horrible for the country truly
truly awful for the country
okay time for a couple of things that I
like so things that I like today I was
reading a couple of books over the
weekend the first was from a guy named
Greg Connolly so I went and visited
Graceland and I realized I didn't know
very much about Elvis so I did what I
always do I went and I got a book on it
so there's a really good book called
being Elvis a lonely life by Ray
Connolly and the book is fun and
well-written and interesting if you're a
fan of Elvis's music then it's a kick so
go check that out ray Connolly's being
Elvis a lonely life really it's an
enjoyable read and I've been getting a
kick out of it as well Elvis is music
he's really he's got an underrated voice
Elvis and the more you listen to him the
more you realized that I was actually
could sing particularly his ballads Love
Me Tender is a really well song song and
the funny thing about Love Me Tender
write which he made really popular is
that it is a 100 year old Confederate
ballot I believe from like the 1860s
1850s 1860s reads on rearranged for a
movie that he made his first movie in
any case you can go check that out okay
other things that I like this week so
Michael Savage who's a radio talk show
host and I disagree with Michael on a
lot of things if you want a window in
to sort of the Trump movement you know
the folks on the left want a window into
the Trump movement they ought to check
out Michael's books because Michael has
been preaching a lot of the same sort of
themes some of which I agree with some
which I disagree with that Trump has
been on for a long time there's a reason
that Trump and Savage were close during
the last election cycle E is a new book
out called stop mass hysteria
America's insanity from the Salem witch
trials to the Trump witch hunts about
the left targeting Trump you know the
left acts like they don't have a window
into the mind of Trump people like the
Trump people are all crazy and that they
don't have anybody articulating their
viewpoint savage is a pretty good
articulator of that viewpoint so if
folks want to know what a lot of the
Trump base is thinking Michael has a
good bead on it go check out stop mass
hysteria that's that's Michael's new
book again don't agree with everything
in the book but I like windows into into
ideas and Michael provides that for sure
okay
other things that I like so bill maher
gets some credit today he was on his
show and this is what I wish we had
talked about when Maher had me on was
the was the evils of political
correctness instead he wanted to talk
Russia for some odd reason but here's
Bill Maher talking about liberals trying
to crack down on people quoting
churchill and how insane all of this is
80% in this new atlantic story that
published this poll 80% of americans see
political correctness as a problem and I
think it's our problem and I don't know
why more mainstream liberals don't
denounce the political correctness that
they must know in private conversations
is insane okay and he's exactly right
about all of this of course a good for
Bill Maher
well you credit when it is due around
here okay time for a couple of things
that I hate so Israel has taken a policy
that I think is very very foolish
there's a policy where basically Israel
has barred unhinged people from
traveling to study in Israel so there's
this woman who's named is Lara al-qasim
she's 22 she's an American student of
Palestinian descent she arrived in
Israel within Israeli issued visa to
study in a master's program at Hebrew
you she never made it out of the airport
Israeli security officials detained her
because of her past membership in
students for justice in Palestine which
is indeed an anti-semitic anti-israel
group they support BDS a boycott
divestment and sanctions policy toward
the Jewish state now she is facing a
deportation here
this is bad politics and it is anti
First Amendment principles now my view
is this the State of Israel does not
have to give citizenship to anybody who
wants to undermine the State of Israel
just as the United States does not have
to give citizenship to anybody who wants
to undermine the the United States of
America as the general rule bringing in
people to study in your country as long
as they are paying their own way and
it's not taking public - I was like I
don't think we should be subsidizing
that in the United States but if
somebody comes here and they are a
socialist for example and they want to
study in an engineering program here and
they want to pay their own way I don't
see a big problem with that and I think
that it would be a mistake for the
United States to bar people based on
political viewpoints except when it
comes to actually becoming citizens and
integrating into the society so Israel
has no need to grant citizenship to this
woman al-qassam they've been doing this
for a few months and I don't think it's
smart in april catherine frank is Barry
Weiss and Bret Stevens reporting at the
New York Times a professor at Columbia
was inter it was interrogated and then
deported from Israel on charges of being
a leader of Jewish Voice for Peace which
is another organization that endorses
BDS in August
Simone Zimmerman an American Jewish
activist who lives in Israel and as a
founder if not now which is a group that
is also Pro BDS was held at the Israeli
border for more than three hours and
quizzed on her political views Peter
Bernard who is an absolute schmuck of a
human being but he is a he's a left-wing
Zionist supposedly he's also quasi Pro
BDS he was on his way to his niece's Bat
Mitzvah in Israel and he was detained in
question this is foolish for people who
are just visiting if you think they're a
national security threat like a real
security threat like they're raising
money against Israel then then you have
every right to be on them but if they're
just there and they're left-wing let
them in make it you know have them leave
on their visa expires and that's that
this is this is bad policy I feel the
same way about Israel as I do about the
United States on free speech basis this
seems counterproductive and foolish I
agree with Brett and Barry when they say
Israel like all countries has a right to
protect its borders and to determine who
is allowed in and out but Israel is also
a state that prides itself on being a
liberal democracy a fact that goes far
to explain the long-standing support for
Israel among American Jews and non-jews
alike
if liberalism is about anything it's
about deep tolerance for opinions we
find foolish dangerous and antithetical
to our own so detaining folks is is not
a worthwhile goal I think this is right
but you don't have to give citizenship
to anybody nor do you have to give
public benefits to anybody and that's
where I would draw the line where I
Israel I feel the exact same way about
the United States okay other things that
I hate so speaking of media bias the
insane piece in the new york times over
the weekend talking about Jared Kushner
and his taxes so ever since nikki Haley
suggested that Jared Kushner is a smart
guy the media have decided that they are
on the warpath for Kushner they have two
separate lines of attack over the past
several days why don't we tag number one
Jared Kushner is close with MBS Muhammad
bin Sultan the Saudi prince responsible
allegedly for the murder of Jamal
khashoggi who is that Saudi dissident so
Jared is close with the Saudi government
therefore it's Jared's fault the Saudi
government did something bad I'd like to
see that logic applied to every American
president for the last 60 years I'd like
to see that logic apply because that
logic simply does not hold if anybody
has an alternative in Saudi Arabia we
can get behind I am happy to hear it
otherwise Jared question are working
with Mohammed bin Sultan before he knew
about a murder seems to me not a
terrible idea considering that Mohammed
it's worth noting here that Mohammed bin
Sultan has been militantly opposed to
the Muslim Brotherhood and also opposed
to the Iranians meaning we have global
interests in the Saudi government we
have actual interest in the Saudi
government that doesn't mean that we
can't snap them when they do something
wrong as we should but to blame Jared
Kushner for this is just ridiculous and
silly the other line of attack that
Jared didn't pay his taxes so according
to the New York Times over the past
decade Jared Kushner's family company
has spent billions of dollars buying
real estate his personal stock
investments have soared his net worth
has quintupled to almost 324 million
dollars and yet for several years
running mr. Kushner appears to have paid
almost no federal income taxes according
to confidential financial documents
reviewed by the New York Times his low
tax bills are the results of a common
tax minimizing maneuver that
year-after-year
generated millions of dollars in losses
for mr. Kushner but the losses were only
on paper because his company didn't
actually appear to lose money the losses
were driven by depreciation which is a
tax benefit that lets real estate
investors deduct a portion of the cost
of their buildings from their taxable
income every year in 2015 for example
Kushner took home 1.7 million dollars in
salary and investment gains but those
earnings were swamped by 8.3 million
dollars of losses largely because of
against appreciation Kushner his company
took on their real estate so here's the
question did he break the law here's the
New York Times nothing in the document
suggest mr. Kushner or his company broke
the law so why is this an article so the
article is Jared Kushner paid his taxes
but he didn't actually owe taxes so he
didn't pay taxes how exactly is that an
attack you know the this it just it's
cynical I mean really that cynical stuff
you don't like the tax code argue
against the tax code but don't blame
people for abiding by the actual law of
the land in the United States okay time
for a quick Federalist paper and then
we'll be out of here so we are all the
way up to Federalists at 47 written by
written by James Madison and this one is
really fascinating because it talks
about the original concept of separation
of powers Madison says that tyranny is a
failure of the separation of powers he
says quote the accumulation of all
powers legislative executive and
judiciary in the same hands whether of
one a few or many and whether hereditary
self-appointed or elective may justly be
pronounced the very definition of
tyranny in other words if you have a
branch that has irrigated to itself
judicial power executive power and
legislative power that would be a
tyranny and he says that if the
Constitution were really chargeable with
the accumulation of that sort of power
then no further arguments would be
necessary to inspire a universal
reprobation of the system he does say
listen there are parts where the
executive does legislative stuff and
parts where the legislative does
executive stuff and part two where the
judiciary does legislative stuff but if
they irrigate extensive and exclusive
power of one of the other branches that
is tyranny say quotes Montesquieu French
philosopher Montesquieu who was the
progenitor of this idea of checks and
balances
he says his meaning as his own words
important and still more conclusively as
illustrated by the example in his I can
amount to no more than this that were
the whole power of one department is
exercised by the same hands which
possessed the whole power of another
Department the fundamental principles of
a free Constitution are subvert 'add
this would have been the case in the
Constitution examined by him if the King
was the sole executive magistrate had
also possessed the complete legislative
power or the supreme administration of
justice Montesquieu objected to the
merger of the executive and the
legislative so here is a quote from
Montesquieu when the legislative and
executive powers are united in the same
person or body there can be no Liberty
because the apprehensions may arise
lest the same monarch or Senate should
enact tyrannical laws to execute them in
a tyrannical manner he said one of the
power of judging joined with the
legislative the life and liberty of the
subject would be exposed to arbitrary
control for the judge would then be the
legislature we're joined to the
executive power the judge might behave
with all the violence of an oppressor so
the argument right now in the United
States is whether this is what's heck
actually happened with the executive
branch the executive branch basically
legislates not basically they do the
regulatory power of the executive branch
is legislative power now you can argue
that's not the whole legislative power
because Congress can trump that a
Congress has failed to trump that if you
actually would like to see a
check-and-balance again Congress has to
take back some of that power Congress is
doing some of that under President Trump
they were involved in in a legislative
move whether they basically were
knocking down regulations at a pretty
rapid rate that's good and necessary the
executive power has also gained the
judiciary power give administrative
agencies with their own hearings boards
this is one of the reasons why there's
been a lot of focus on a case called
chevron chevron is a supreme court case
in which the Supreme Court suggested the
judiciary has to grant administrative
deference to administrative agencies so
you have a case in front of the EPA you
go to the EPA board the EPA
Administrative Board gives you a
judicial decision the question is
whether the judiciary can trump that
decision Chevron says in many cases no
that's why Chevron is wrong
it's why justice Gorsuch has opposed
Chevron it's why justice Cavanaugh
opposed to chevron chevron should be
struck down just for these checks and
balances to be restored irrigation of
too much power in one branch is the
essence of tyranny that remains as true
today as when the Constitution was
written okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with all of the latest presumably
including full stories of Elizabeth
Warren's time with the Native American
tribes writing the crab ridden plains of
Oklahoma we'll have all of it for you
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing